哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿
放心說我是周慕姿心理師
今天又來到了十分鐘心理學
我想要跟大家
討論的這個主題
是關於大家在工作中常常會
遇到的一個狀況
那就是我到底是過勞、
burn out
還是悶爆、
bull out
就是無聊到爆
好 關於這一個
主題為什麼會想討論
是因為我發現有
很多人常常會覺得
好累喔 不想上班
因此講到好累我不想上班
全部的人都會有一些想像
因為你覺得好累
因為你上班很辛苦
因為你很過勞
但是其實不想
上班有很多原因
我覺得很煩
主管很很很愛念人
主管很愛念人
自己是主管覺得下屬
都不好好工作
然後或是我的上頭更麻煩
然後跟公司的
一些想法不一樣
現在做的事情太無聊
還有就是
欸我其實做的事情喔
累的半死
但是我不知道
我的意義是什麼
所以你就會發現一件事
不想上班這件事情
其實有很多原因
可是你到底是因為過勞
還是因為悶爆呢
也就是你是因為
你做這些事情
你不會覺得很無聊
你覺得很有意義
但是你被要求跟被
就是放了太多的工作
還是因為你
實在是覺得太無聊
而你的過勞是
因為工作量太高
還是你心理上的
情緒勞悶太高呢
我想今天就是要
跟大家來討論一下
關於這兩個部分的不同
以及你到底是哪一個部分
首先我們先來聊一下
所謂的burn out
就是我們所謂的過勞喔
過勞這件事情
大家應該很容易理解
最常遇到的就是
長期承受過量的工作壓力
導致你的情緒浩劫
而且身心俱疲
這個部分大家有
很多的想像包含
比如說有些人他的工作呢
是在可能很知名的大企業
做一些工程師
可是要on call
所以就是隨時被叫
就要被隨時電話一來
然後工廠有什麼問題
他就要被叫回去
當然也有一些人
他的on
call是跟生命有關的
比如說從事像醫生的工作
或是他是在醫院擔任
像心理師 社工師
或是一些就是
跟生命比較有關
然後別人的身心狀況
有關的一些工作呢
他可能也會有
這樣子的壓力喔
比如說像我們心理師工作
很多人就會問說
老師你們會不會常常
聽人家負面的事情
結果呢
就覺得自己心理壓力很大
然後呢很難排解
我誠實的跟大家講
其實永遠最辛苦的
都不會是因為聽
別人講負面的事情
所以心理壓力很大
對於心理師來說
有很多時候是包含了
對方在說的事情
是不是會勾起
我們的一些情緒
跟感受
我們會不會因為對方的一些
談話的內容
我們心裡有一些就是
因為跟他起了共鳴之後
事後回到家
我開始一直想
他的這個問題
怎麼辦呢
要怎麼處理呢
我對他有沒有幫助呢
還是怎麼做才會比較好呢
他這樣子感覺怎麼樣呢
當下跟他的感同身受
其實不會造成
我們這麼大的情緒壓力
比較大的情緒壓力
反而是我們對於
他的這個狀態
我們在面對的時候
我們的感受是什麼
而我們又怎麼看待
跟怎麼定義這件事情
比如說我是一個覺得
我一定要很有責任感
我要是一個很有效能心理師
如果我是這麼看待自己
我聽到對方的一些
面對的一些困難
有些困難是
你沒有辦法幫助他處理的
比如說
他現在面對了
包含關係的破裂
例如說重要他人的離去
包含是生死一體
或者是他現在就是
欠了一大筆錢
然後或者是他被
詐騙集團騙了
然後他現在那筆錢就是
拿不回來等等
這些東西你幾乎沒有幫
你幾乎沒有辦法幫他處理
這個問題的時候
如果你是一個
覺得自己應該要
讓個案來找你
就要好一點的心理師
而你沒有留意到
你現在需要陪伴他去處理的
陪伴他去面對的心理的狀態
是什麼的時候
你可能會把他的問題
當成你的問題
然後在日常生活中
就不停不停地去思考
這個部分才是會讓我們
變得很容易過勞的一個狀態
也就是你把別人的問題
當成自己的問題
你的情緒界限不清
可是在我們工作上
會不會因為界限問題過勞呢
非常容易
特別是如果你的工作本身
會有很多的需要
負擔比較大責任
甚至呢
你其實必須要跟生死有關
比如說警察相關工作
或者是像醫療相關工作
幾乎很容易遇到生死議題
遇到每一個人生命中
最辛苦的時候
人非草木啊
起能無感
所以我們在看的時候
我們一定會有很多的心情
很多的感受
可是遇到這樣的感受
不知道怎麼排解
不知道怎麼處理
甚至我根本沒有時間
排解跟處理的時候
他就會成為我很嚴重的
情緒勞務
甚至我會出現替代性創傷
就是我會出現
他發生的事情
很像我發生一樣
於是我就會有很多
很多的情緒壓力
例如說我以前有遇到一些
就是工作上是
醫療相關的朋友
可能例如他們在看到一些
社會案件的時候
可能送過來的受害者
就是他們現在在接手的
因此他們獲得的那個
情緒的那個張力
還有他的替代性創傷
會比一般人多很多
也包含如果你是社工相關
你常常必須要面對很多類似
就是家庭暴力
或者是一些我們
在日常生活看了
會覺得很痛心的一些案件
這些東西也會造成
我們的情緒勞務變得比較高
因為我們一個人
能夠承擔的情緒是有限的
因此我們會很容易對工作
漸漸冷漠失去熱情
這就是所謂過勞最容易
對我們帶來的影響
因此過勞的人最需要的
其實是不能再跟自己講
我可以撐下去
我可以在人內
而是要開始設立自己
情緒跟工作的界限
當然這也包含了
在你工作裡面
常常必須要承擔某些人
對你的一些情緒
或者是一些要求對你來說
是不合理的
甚至你有遭受到一些
職場上一些
壓迫啊
不公平的對待人等
也很容易會出現這些
過度的情緒勞務跟過勞
所以對於這一類的朋友來說
找到補充能量的方式
跟建立界限
就會是一件非常重要的關鍵
再來是另外一個部分
就是今天我們談到
的另外一個重點
那就Ball out
就是無聊到爆
悶爆的心理狀態
這種狀態其實很
常出現在什麼
工作挑戰不足
缺乏意義感
所以你平常結束的時候
工作結束的時候
你雖然覺得很累
可是那個類是覺得空虛
覺得冷
然後甚至會覺得說
我今天一整天不知道在幹嘛
所以那個類是
覺得很空虛的累
這種常見的狀況
其實是工作太瑣碎
或是太簡單
甚至你的上班
時間常常在裝忙
可是你不知道你做這些事情
你沒有意義感
然後在這個過程中
你就會開始問你自己
這真的是我想要的人生嗎
我這樣真的會覺得比較好嗎
我的人生
這一輩子就是這樣了嗎
這種東西很常出現
就是有一些人會講
你要把一個人養廢
怎麼做呢
就是把它找來給他很多錢
但是給他的工作非常簡單
他會變成廢人
這件事情非常重要
因為如果你認為
或是這個社會告訴你
錢多 事少 離家近
這件事情就是很棒
你的人生這樣就夠了
於是你每天可能
拿很多很多錢
可是你工作派給
你的工作量很少
又很簡單
你一下子就做完了
你不知道幹嘛
你就滑手機
或是做自己的事情
他每天這樣混
好像也沒有幹嘛
一天就這樣過去了
好像也很不錯
可是不知道
為什麼你覺得很空虛
這個就很可能是悶爆的原因
大家可能會覺得
老師這個感覺很像是
有錢人的煩惱
就是能夠有這種
工作真的很不錯
倒是不一定
舉個例
像現在在脆上面
常常會有人會聊到說
比如說你在工作
了一段時間之後
爸爸媽媽突然告訴你
我們家其實是有錢人
你有很多的房產
所以從此之後
你可以不用再工作了
全部人就說天啊
這也太幸福了吧
怎麼會有這種事
我覺得這件事情
放在怎麼樣的人會很幸福呢
就是你已經有你
自己想做的事情
你也有你自己
想要的方向跟目標
於是這件事情發生的
的好處是讓
你可以比較放心的
沒有經濟壓力的
去追求你人生想要的目標
跟你想做的事情
這就是一個很大的禮物
那如果你是一個
從你錢到現在就知道
我家很有錢
我家有房產
我只要收租就好
我不用去做其他事情
然後對我來說
其實我永遠不用擔心錢的事
這並不是讓一個人
覺得幸福快樂的狀況
反而是我聽到有很多例子
是當他是這樣過生活的時候
他的日常生活自己的生活
其實是一團亂的
甚至會有很多包含酒的上癮
或是要酒飲的一個狀況
這是非常非常常見
因此對於這一些
很容易覺得說
我的生活很無聊
我沒有意義感
我不知道我做
這些工作要幹什麼
然後我做事情很無聊
即使薪水ok我
還是覺得很無聊的人
最需要的其實不是休息
而是必須要找到你生活
人生目的的意義感跟挑戰
他不一定要工作
可是這一件
這一個挑戰
不一定要在工作裡面
可是他需要在你的生命中
有這樣子的挑戰跟目的
例如如果你發現
你有這個狀況
試著問問自己
如果沒有限制
我想像中最想要的生活
是長什麼樣子呢
把這個想像當成
你人生的指南針
可以幫助你去找到一個切口
去讓你重新探索
你的人生有沒有一些可能性
有沒有可能更
接近你想要的生活
而我認為這是
生命中每一個人
都該為自己去負的責任
也是我們可以給自己的禮物
就是我這輩子來這個世界
老天到底要我做什麼事
所以在這裡我再做一個補充
這可以讓我們看到
過勞跟悶暴的差別
其實就是我心裡的浩解
跟我心裡的空虛
所以過勞是我們的能量
被過度的消耗
所以人被榨乾
悶爆呢
則是我的能量
有很多很多的能量
可是沒有地方用
所以我的能量沒有出口
所以人被困住
因此一個是消耗殆盡
另外一個東西就是燜燒
反而是燒不出來
然後就很容易爆炸
所以你到底是過勞還是悶爆
你是因為做太多
還是做太少的痛苦呢
在這裡我提供幾個小問題
讓大家可以問問自己
做一下自我檢測
例如第一
下班後
你是覺得累到不行
還是覺得空虛覺得冷
第二個問題
你最常冒出的念頭
是覺得我已經快撐不下去了
還是這有什麼意義呢
第三個問題
你在工作的時候
或是你在生命中
有沒有在做什麼事情的時候
覺得天啊我好喜歡喔
我好想要為
這件事情再做下去
沒有考慮錢
沒有考慮
他是不是可以得到
很多很多的成果
還是說你大部分的時候都是
覺得說
欸我做這件事情到底要幹嘛
到底要做什麼
這一題特別是給
容易覺得悶爆
可是我搞不清楚
自己是什麼狀況的人
去思考
原因是因為過勞
很容易可以發現
但是剛剛我們
說的那個悶爆呢
其實很容易會忽略
甚至會覺得自己人
在福中不知福喔
這在我們社會的主流價值
其實常常會出現這樣的問題
最後呢我想跟大家分享
那如果我已經知道
我是過勞還是悶爆
我要怎麼調整呢
首先過勞剛剛前面我有提
第一個學會畫清
工作跟情緒的界限
並且懂得拒絕
對你來說懂的拒絕這件事情
不是只有我不要
而是我要怎麼提出一個
對方可以理解我的這個不要
不等不但是為了保護我自己
而且呢是為了讓我
可以持續這個工作
讓你們比較不麻煩
並且第二個尋求對你來說
真正的放鬆跟能量補給
特別是過勞的人
一天到晚都在
就是輸出
怎麼樣輸入這件事情
其實對過勞的人特別重要
每個人輸入的方式不一樣
可能不只是睡覺
有些人說我靠睡覺就好
很有可能
可是我自己在過勞的時候
我會發現不同的情況
有不同的做法
比如說有的時候是
因為工作時間過長
這件事情我沒有
留時間給自己
我可能就需要給自己比較
大塊的時間休息
然後放空什麼事情都不做
就真的閒在哪裡
什麼事情都不做
但如果我發現我
今天是用腦過度
比如說前陣子入課的時候
我發現我真的太累了
因此我會做的讓自己
可以能量補給的方法
反而是讓自己去跑一跑
跑一跑不讓自己可以
做一些動態的冥想
反而對我是一個幫助
因此去找到屬於你
真正的能量補給
是一件非常重要的事情
再來第三
有過勞習慣的人
其實很容易都有完美主義
也就是我一定要
完美的這件事情
我一定要把每件事情做好
甚至可能就會是
我們之前在講
停止內耗課程中的高功能的
生存策略者
就很容易會出現這樣
所以讓你可以把一定要完美
的念頭放鬆下來
允許自己不用
樣樣都做到最好
可能也是一個
提醒自己的方式
接下來呢是悶爆
悶爆的朋友建議你
不要一直在想說等環境改變
了再做些什麼
而是可以試著主動去尋找
主動去尋求挑戰
因為有些時候我如果
下定決心要換掉這個
別人看起來表面上
好像還不錯的東西
其實是會讓你有壓力的話
讓你自己去主動尋求挑戰
就是一種方式哦
但是有的時候可能
你主動尋求挑戰
不一定知道往哪邊走
所以去想像你想要的生活
你想要的未來是什麼樣子
然後讓自己可以用
一個一個的小行動
越來越靠近你想要的生活
不過如果你的環境沒有辦法
提供成長機會
就可以思考轉換跑道
例如說我以前也曾經
在一個大企業工作
大概五六年的時間
在那五六年間
我其實不停的提醒自己說
我可以看一下在
這一個工作上
我還可以學到什麼
我還可以做些什麼
所以我的工作
內容非常非常多元
也很多事情都要做
但是在做到五六年之後
我發現這一個工作的環境
他好像已經沒有辦法
提供我成長機會了
而我越來越清楚
我有想要就是
我想要過的生活
是什麼樣子的
在那個時候我就開始決定
我想要轉換跑道
那麼如果我今天留在那邊
有沒有什麼好處跟壞處呢
好處是他真的很穩定
但壞處就是我可能會有很多
我想要成為的部分
我想要做到的
事情沒有辦法做到
因此這一切都只是選擇
所以最後提醒大家
不論你是過勞還是悶爆
可能我們最後
都會有類似的感覺
就是會覺得很厭倦
很厭世
甚至很沮喪跟失去方向
但是這兩個部分在
我們剛剛的分享
你可能會發現
他們的根本原因
根本是不同的
一個是做太多你沒有力氣了
你需要充電
另外一個是做太少
結果你的電都
不知道用到哪裡去
你就一直電自己
因此希望你可以
稍微留意一下
常常出現在你心裡
的那句話是什麼
如果你常常說的是
我覺得好累哦
我快撐不下去了
這一種感覺
那你可能處在過勞
如果你常常說的是
天啊這好無聊哦
有什麼意義啊
幹嘛要做這個啊
你可能現在悶爆的情緒裡面
所以最後我請大家
也許你可以問問你自己
現在的你是在燃燒殆盡
還是困在悶爆的情緒裡面呢
歡迎大家也可以
留言跟我分享
現在的你是過勞還是悶爆
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉拜拜